just like any other grouping brackets
absolute value science should always be
dealt with first right deal with the
stuff inside and then expand outlets so
in this case the deepest thing you see
inside this expression is 11 take away
16 which of course is 5 I'm going to
encourage you as much as possible in
these early stages particularly feel
you're like I've never met this before
really to go skip that line right even
though I can see pretty quickly once I
get comfortable with this ok the
absolute value of nearly 5 is 5 and I
think once you become more fluent with
this just go straight to find now you
can see it just write it down but while
we're developing the idea just kidding
you comfortable with it do this line 5
take away your 3 not high okay now when
you have a look at the next question
let's do mr. Tracy
now I'm still dealing with numbers but
now we're being asked to solve an
equation okay there are two ways that
this is going to play out I want you to
think back to our definitions think back
to our definitions I think probably the
most helpful one is going to be this one
group in this definition you see that
this looks very much like this okay I'm
going to use that definition to split
this absolute value apart into two
pieces so I'm literally gonna split it
across and we call these things because
it's like there might be this it might
be that we call them cases so I'm gonna
name this case one case two yeah the
absolute value X minus three X is a
variant that means X minus three is also
a variable so sometimes you might be
this one and sometimes you might be this
one they're different cases and
different things result so good case 1
where X minus 3 is negative and then the
other case is where X minus 3 is not
okay so I'm going to take them one at
time let's have a look over here
left-hand side if X minus 3 is negative
what's the absolute value of X minus 2
look at your definitions
if it's negative you switch this thing
around right so be three months X so
I've taken that absolute value thing and
I'm simple if this is what happens this
is what you're really equals with that
equals seven can we go ahead and solve
this I'm going to subtract three from
both sides
and Athleta solution you happy with that
you've done one case you've dealt with
it
now you look over the other one you say
well if X minus three is positive then
the absolute value of X minus three is
it's just X minus three all right so it
stays what it is that you can go ahead
and you can solve okay so what have you
done this single equation has two
solutions and just like we had before if
you've got multiple things like when
we're solving simultaneous equations
with three unknowns you should do the
marker favor and highlight what you
don't certain they can see